I anagrams three names so far Emma grams
oh the names aren't here though oh this
will be difficult to Hannah grant by the
end of the game I'll have an anagram for
this let's play the e for Sandy dears
sandy dears is an anagram of syed nasir
oh no it's not
Oh cuz I already use a D well let's play
so I play this garbage you anagon so you
rearrange the letters to form a a word
or a string of words like Scrabble okay
I give up I have to focus on the chest I
like the position though I like the Fein
cattle about the Queen here expecting
Bishop e7 like a castle I don't think
I'm getting punished at some point Queen
g3t or maybe chat can anagram
interesting either grams in the chat
let's play king b1 yeah so trademark
that Scrabble chess
chasuble weight chest will exist so I
was trying to combine the words easy
Anders hmm okay I'm threatening like
dirty stuff like look at these bishops
it's like a Danish gambit except I
didn't sack any pawns have a full
full-out attack nights like tins of the
Bishop tied down to each southern pawn
go to this box to each six reasonable
okay let's push it G pawn like each six
is a sign that y wants to play g5 if
Knight okay so 95 defends the bishop but
then still g5 yeah this is so nice
Oh your ends your ends oh that's so
fitting for the time of year but there's
an extra a so we need we would need a
year and a year ends that's nice that's
the best one it's most fitting most
relevant Wow a point wants to me me
before I made opponent the thing is
Bloxom only threatening oh maybe two
checks
mmm-hmm I just want to sack a queen you
take here I just spoke as gambit again
yeah this is my life now but I scanned
it because I'm it's so fun to win the
pawn and it takes and then just meeting
Bishop so strong I don't know if this
will go on YouTube but maybe it will
yeah it probably will I was trying to
slow down with the protest cam videos
but it's just too fun like Ritchie one
coming not easy for block to stop if
this site I do this and of this I again
Ritchie one or G one coming in all these
lines maybe even rip DG one like g6 work
DG one and then push to H pawn so nice
Bishop I could be in keto in black store
territory
I could also play h4 h5 immediately ah
too much fun
yeah there's no [ __ ] bout six I've
pawned tied down to G pawn king just
kind of stuck h5 incoming I'm almost out
of tea but that's okay position makes up
for it mmm what is this Knight g5 95 is
threatening me than one oh my gosh takes
takes takes meets wait a minute no it's
me it's forced me already look at this
oh it's so beautiful
h7 pawn sacrifice even better than the
movie King has to take and then I take
discover check and then eventually King
g8 and then mate
what a finish well the game I was so
nice yeah my queen wasn't necessary to
finish off the attack
the chat is already saying hello to
YouTube
I guess it's my job to say goodbye to
YouTube thanks for watching stay tuned
for more content subscribe I'll be
uploading more videos to come
I'll see you in the future